at that point uh the meeting is being
recorded and broadcast on the website
okay I'll now introduce the top table um
from democratic Services we've got Kera
Keller our solicitor this evening is Sue
Mullins our planning manager is David
Jeffrey and our planning officers are
Emma Booker and Sarah Leech uh David you
got a statement prepared I do thank you
chair my name is David Jeffrey I'm the
planning manager for tonight's meeting
my role is to provide impartial advice
to clarify any planning issues that
arise and to assist members in their
decision taking planning committee
members are not bound by advice from
officers or by their
recommendations thank you very much okay
we can move on to the agenda then item
one apologies for absence we have no
apologies for absence okay thank you
very much item two disclosures of
interest uh councelor Parry
first thank you and good evening chair
um I just wish to declare an interest um
I am known or have been known to the
applicants of the first application the
River Meadow dog walking um because one
of the applicants um certainly
uh was facilitated one of my my
daughter's children's parties it must be
about 30 years ago I haven't been in
contact with them since I also wish to
declare I'm a dog owner but I live a
very good Fair distance away from
Clipper Chambers so would never um if if
the application was approved would be
using it so I come to the meeting with
an open mind chair thank you very much
Council
pton thank you chairman much like uh
every other member of the committee I've
had correspondence forwarded to me in
relation to the first item on the agenda
I'm also the Cy canselor that covers
that particular area uh but I don't
believe that that creates any uh issue
around um uh conflict of interest uh but
for clarity site declare the interest
and come to it with an open mind thank
you very much and yes um we have been
sent as committee members um information
from um interested parties in relation
to Le first applications I'd expect a
blanket dispensation councelor Harvey
thank you chairman um uh given that
councel Parry has mentioned that she's a
dog owner I feel obliged to mention that
I'm a dog owner I've never walked by dog
in Clifford Chambers or anywhere near it
um and I also need to declare that I
made a visit to the site this morning uh
and I drove up and down Main Street
that's all I did didn't speak to anybody
I come to the discussion with an open
mind thank you very much for
completeness I'll state that I'm also a
dog owner um however I don't live
anywhere near the application
site um councelor Keith
Le thank you chair uh yeah um I'm the
ward member for this application number
three dog walking field um I need to
declare that I I made a site visit um I
did so uh having previously spoken with
the case officer to make sure that that
was in order I went around with the
applicants but I kept an open mind and I
stated the applicants I wasn't going to
make a decision or comment one way or
the other I have had quite a bit of
lobbying from objectors including the
parish council uh like yourselves I've
received received emails but I've not
expressed an opinion I've come to
committee to listen to this um from both
sides to keep an open mind on the
application tonight thank you okay thank
you very much councilor Keithley and uh
welcome coun passingham as well sorry uh
I appreciate there's traffic in town
tonight um we're just on disclosures of
interest um if there aren't any further
disclosures of Interest sorry Council
um I too am a dog owner um my dogs do
use um these types of enclosed Fields
however um I've never use this
particular field so I also come to this
with an open
mind thank you very much okay I think
that's it for disclosures of Interest
which case we can move on to our first
item which is item three application
23239 0/ Barry River Meadow dog walking
rear of 12 Clifford Chambers Clifford
Chambers and our presenting officer is
Emma Booker when you're ready feel free
to take it
away thank you chair so the first item
uh before members tonight as the chair
has said um is located in Clifford
Chambers
it relates to or the application as just
say relates to A variation of an extent
planning permission which permitted the
use of the site as a dog walking
facility the site is located to the rear
of Main Street in the village of
Clifford Chambers and on this map
members can see the
proximity of the site to strapford upon
aen the site lies adjacent to the
conservation area and contributes to the
setting of several listed buildings also
detailed on this map are the two public
rights of way that are in proximity to
the site however do not cross it um so
there's one to the north of the river
and the other running along the close
which is to the east of the application
site slightly more zoomed in map now so
um members can see the relationship that
the site has with the adjacent
Neighbors in the main these are
characterized by larger dwellings which
are set within spacious
plots on this um map you can see that
the site is access from Main Street down
a track that's wide enough for a single
vehicle there's a gate towards the far
end which secures the site and customers
can park within this first field where
there's space uh for at least two
vehicles and there's also sufficient
turning space is demonstrated here so
that Vehicles can enter in a forward
gear I'll now show you some pictures of
the site so this is the access
down this is where um the on-site
parking uh is
located so the Green Arrow shows what
direction um the photo has been taken
neighboring properties
here again same thing showing the
boundary
treatments so as you saw in the site
location plan um the site is bound on
one side by the r
St um and this is Main Street this photo
was taken this morning so you can see um
the level of on street parking
there so the applicant is seeking to
gain approval for a variation to the
permitted opening hours larger group
sizes and an increase in the permitted
number of bookings per day the
conditions proposed by officers differ
from those proposed by the applicant and
the ones proposed are considered to meet
the test of reasonableness and to permit
a change of uh a use of the site that
conforms to the adopted development plan
policies uh your attention is drawn to
the update sheet which details um
additional correspondence that we've
received since uh the publication of the
report and that concludes my
presentation thank
you thank you very much Emma okay uh we
can now move on then to our first
Speaker who is councelor Jonathan tribe
from from uh Clifford Chambers Parish
Council good evening councelor uh so
you've got three minutes in total uh
just uh yes correct yeah and um I'm
happy to give you a 30 second warning if
you'd like just before times
up yes correct so it's the button on the
right hand side which um makes the red
light go on and then uh when you're
ready feel free to take it
away Jonathan tribe chair of Clifford
Chambers and milk Paris Council as
councilors will see the parish council
objected this application on a number of
planning grounds firstly it's hard to
justify this activity as a rural
business as it provides no
employment conditions were instigated
less than a year ago on the request of
the same case officer to mitigate the
identified harm to local residents no
risk assessment has been conducted so
there is no justification for relaxing
the necessary mitigations that were
imposed then all nine objectives are
local
residents letters of support do not
represent any local views as these are
typically from Coventry Kennelworth
bad uh all of which drive past similar
dog walking businesses to arrive at
Clifford Chambers this development does
not serve local demand but causes local
harm the planning application is
incorrect when the applicants state that
they own all the affected land
they do not they have not served notice
on other land owners making this
application
invalid access to the field is only
possible via a narrow single track Lane
which is not owned by the applicants the
owners of the lane were not notified of
this application and have written to the
case officer serving notice that they
intend to erect an electric gate denying
dog Walker's vehicle or access this
would mean that all vehicles would try
to find parking in the already saturated
Village
where parking stress results in damage
to curbs Pavements verges in our
conservation Village parking on the Main
Street often results in cars barely able
to pass and their fears that emergency
vehicles may not get not get through
local highways authorities objected to
this application on parking
grounds our neighborhood plan States new
development should not result in
inappropriate traffic generation or have
any acceptable adverse impacts on road
safety development proposals should not
compromise Road Safety or increase
congestion within the neighborhood area
particularly along Main Street this
proposal would unacceptably further
compound existing parking
stress the site is not secure as the
fence fences are mostly domestic garden
fences owned by neighboring homes
erecting a 6-ft
fence um is objected to by the case
officer who who stated that 6ot fence
would not be appropriate and would um
compromise the cons Conservation Area
setting with the open public views and
public rights aways the PC continues to
receive complaints regarding noise dogs
escaping into neighbor's Gardens on one
occasion entering a disabled residence
home and jumping on her while she was in
her wheelchair parking issues block
drives and garages and near accidents
have been reported there's no
justification for relaxing this restrict
which were deemed appropriate only 9
months ago the decision is contrary to
I'll ask you to wrap it up there on that
one please may I just finish yes on that
sentence thank you I would fly in the
face of planning law local democracy the
planning U the development as proposed
would be contrary to development plans
policies tt1 tt2 ne2 all of our made
neighborhood plan relating to parking
highway safety and local C I'll ask you
to end it there thank you okay uh
members uh do we have any question
questions for our Parish
Council Council
key thank you good evening John um I've
heard um many people objecting to this
commenting on the parking issues in the
village um tonight we've seen a
photograph of Main
Street um there actually are plenty of
spaces there I come to the Village quite
a lot some times there are events on at
the Village Hall and at the club next
door um you know if there are parties
and events and then um there are there
are more more cars what evidence have
you got to show that that with the
amount of uh traffic will be generated
by the activities on the field that in
fact parking would actually be a problem
on the on on Main Street where people
are entitled to park unrestricted in any
any case because my experience has been
that it's not the problem that the
parish council is making it out to
be I would suggest the parish council um
we're not uh in the business of making
um uh loose um accusations when we've
got a problem we we highlight it and
that's our job we're highlighting the
issues in our own Community um on the
parish
council um we over 100 Years of um
experience living in Clifford Chambers
parking is an enormous problem I don't
know when that photograph was taken but
that is not typical whatsoever
um very often and this has been
highlighted you wouldn't get uh parking
on both sides of the road it's not
designed for you wouldn't get something
the size of um an emergency vehicle
through particularly not a fire engine
so this is quite a critical um aspect in
Clifford Chambers it's a no through Road
as you know
um it most properties do not have
Offroad
parking the direction of travel in all
our society is um higher levels of
occupancy and higher levels of car
ownership this problem is only going to
get worse the main issue with this
application is it's the right idea it's
in completely the wrong place it's on a
flood plane there there's no sorry I'll
just Council Kei only asked you about
parking so I'll ask you to restrict your
answer to that thank Youk thanks chair
uh members any further questions
councilor
Harvey thank you chairman um am I right
in thinking that this uh business
operates on the basis that uh people are
walking their dogs Park their cars on on
the site what I'm what I'm getting at is
um to what extent have you got
experience and evidence that dog walk
Walkers don't park in the field where
the where the where the parking spaces
are or me how much parking in your
experience and with what evidence can
you show is actually on Main Street as a
result of this business um on many
occasions I've personally seen um dog
walkers personally asking for this where
the site is and then I've observed them
parking on on the Main Street um there
are two parking spaces as has been said
up that narrow Drive what hasn't been
highlighted is any Vehicles there's a
resident um there's a property up there
with residents um when they're emerging
from their um home then any car meeting
them on that single Lane has to reverse
blind over a pavement into a Road
between Park cars we've had um reports
of uh pedestrians nearly be knocked down
and and a motorcyclist nearly been
um well an accident nearly caused by
somebody emerging blind it's the site is
inappropriate and potentially
dangerous any further questions for
parent Council councelor hen San good
evening um you say the access is owned
by another person yes but is it a right
away access it's a restricted as I
understand is restricted um for
agricultural purposes only my
understanding is that um um slist has
been instructed and have instructed the
applicants of that and again my
understanding is that the um owners of
that access um have written to the case
officer and stated their
intent potentially to put an electric
gate as I've mentioned which would block
all access so then all parking would be
in the village and and highways of
objectiv on on parking grounds
and a very quick one from Council yeah
just a follow up to your comment there
John that vehicles are reversing blind
back into the road we just heard from
the case officer that there is turning
space available at the bottom of the
field and and I'm aware there's space on
the drive of the property on the way
down that lane as well um so I don't
understand why people would reverse
blind up that lane well well as I
mentioned when a car um um meets the
other car the car the resident driving
out they meet potentially halfway down
the lane now if the first um if if the
one emerging from their home doesn't
reverse then the one entering the dog
walker has to reverse um back blind over
the pavement and out and that's happened
on several occasions um the owner of the
house who's not resident at the moment
are elderly and they couldn't turn their
head so they couldn't um reverse easily
and so um on occasions they have told me
me um they would be met in the lane
which is single track and the dog
walkers would have to reverse back okay
thank you John okay thank you any
further questions in which case uh
councel tribe thank you very much for
your contribution thank
you we now move on to our next speaker
who is Andrew
Musgrave good evening Mr mrave um so
similarly you've got three minutes um
um it's the button on the right hand
side um to turn the red light on I'm
happy to give you a 30 second warning um
before your three minutes is
up that's right yeah and uh when you're
ready take it away uh good evening uh my
name is Andrew Musgrave and my wife and
I have lived next to the field for 30
years um forgive me I'm no longer used
to speaking in public so forgive me if I
read this
out I'm here today to comment on the
recommendations made by the case officer
in the committee report and to make
requests for some minor amendments to be
incorporated regarding condition two
which is to do with the timings um they
seem to me to be a reasonable compromise
between the interests of the applicant
and those of the surrounding
Neighbors on condition three which is
the limit of people per visit the
existing limit of three people visit was
not only what the case officer
recommended it was what the applicant
requested in the original
application so committee may like to
inquire because I can't answer a
question what has happened in the
intervening 9 months to require the
limit to be doubled to
six not withstanding that if the limit
is to be increased to permit family
groups as in the officers report may I
request consideration be given to
structuring it accordingly for example
all the six people permitted may be no
more than four to be adults with the
remainder being
children this would reduce the
likelihood of the large noisy groups of
adults that we experience during the
period the field was operating without
planning
permission lastly condition four which
is a number of visits per day in the
committee report as you will have noted
no doubt it is stated that the increase
from six P visits per day to eight is to
reflect the extended times of
operation this being the case may I
request that consideration is given to
the increased number of visits applying
in the summer period only when the hours
are
extended and the limit reverting to six
in Autumn winter and spring thank you
for your
attention thank you very much and well
within your time members do we have any
questions uh for Mr Musgrave Castle
Perry thank you and good evening and
thank you for your presentation this
evening um obviously you're um a
neighbor to this particular facility um
and there have been concerns by other
objectors in terms of noise generated
can you just give me a bit of an
indication of the sort of typical noise
levels that you have experience so far
during its current operation well during
its current operation uh it's a
restricted amount that was allowed for
in the planning permission the field
operated for approximately three years
before that without planning permission
therefore without any restrictions um we
heard substantial noise people calling
out shouting to each other we've seen
football games we've seen frisbee games
happening all sorts of things aren't
just dog walking since the application
was approved in February with the limit
to three we tend to find the people are
there to walk a dog as opposed to have a
nice day out in the countryside with a
dog being incidental to it now I'm not
against people enjoying the countryside
but what you licensed was a dog walking
field not a public
park so in addition to noise luckily or
unluckily for us our house which which
is in Parts nearly 400 years old looks
out over the field we have had people
stood at our fence doing this in order
to be able to look into our living room
as a result we've had to plant
edges which costs money not to put too
fine a point on it uh and uh We've so
we've had intrusion in a number of ways
people look in sometimes it's just that
natural glance that you do when you're
walking past somewhere you can do it
when you're walking down the street
sometimes it's
staring uh we've had people making a
noise loud telephone
conversations one time we had another
set of neighbors with us in just sitting
on our own patio uh and there was a loud
party decided to roost if I can put it
that way underneath our oak tree uh and
make it so can I give you debel levels
can I give you hours of extent of of
noise no I can't but we do get quite a
lot of noise when there's a lot of
people thank you any further questions C
strander hi thank you for the
information you provided could I just
ask for a little bit more detail on that
last question so when you talk about the
period preceding um the the current
situation and you described those levels
of noise would you say those were groups
of people that exceeded six that were
particularly problematic um they
certainly exceeded three uh once you get
to four you quite often will be able to
observe they go into two parties so two
people will be walking with a dog and
the other two may go off from walking
the other dog Direction Just because
they like the river or whatever I don't
know why they do it um so yes it did
sometimes include I think the largest
party we saw is probably about 11 or 12
um but also and to be fair that was in
lockdown when maybe some of these rules
should be bent um but uh yes we've seen
all sorts of sides the party that I just
referred to as roosting underneath our
uh um our tree was uh uh from memory
four or five and it sounded like they'd
had what my father would have called a
good lunch and they were making quite a
lot of
noise any further
questions no in which case thank you
very much for your contribution this
evening thank
you okay we move on to our final
speakers for the uh this item then which
uh are Mrs Linda Pollock and Sarah
Hoskin want first um well I've got you
both down together and you've got six
minutes between you um you're welcome to
split that how you would
like good
evening uh very very quickly um so how
how would you like to split the time you
have one and a half minutes one and a
half minutes for you yourself yes very
good would you like any warning before
that's
up 30
seconds just
stop if you could press the button on
the right hand side and then you can
take it away thank you I wish to support
this application because the use of this
7 and a half acre Meadow I mean it's big
which is bounded by the river star for
dog walking and activities associated
with dogs for the disabled
and local families and there are many
local families this is appropriate in my
view for the site which I know
well it is well conducted by its owners
who respect the
rurality they use no fertilizers or weed
killers they plant indigenous species in
quantity trees and bushes they maintain
the river banks from erosion and Pollard
The Willows professionally to that they
offer this lovely Meadow for for the
benefit of many it is a magnificent
facility that deserves support not
opposition objections Accord with the
increasing urbanization of rural
Villages about which I have written
extensively my book is in your planning
department rural Villages such as
Clifford Chambers whereby rural
typically country Pursuits such as dog
exercise and dog handling are
misunderstood and
disliked frankly we sometimes fear our
Parish Council when it tends to react to
planning issues such as this one
according to personalities and and
personal preferences ignoring the
relevant issues and I have personally
suffered from
this thank
you thank you very much um just just
over your minute and a half um as I I
say you've um got some time left for
your other speaker did they want to come
up now and we can have questions to both
of you at the end that's absolutely fine
should I stay or go um if you'd like to
stay that would probably be easier thank
you it's Miss Pollock I understand do I
um yes it's it's ready on so when you're
ready take it away y good evening my
name's Linda Pollock I met you many of
you the first time around I've sent you
all photographs of the site um which I
was too late to do today because my
computer broke down so um I sent them to
you under a separate email I've also
sent you details of why I object to the
objectives um our field first started
because we volunteer for a charity
called dogs for good they train dogs to
work work with people with wheelchairs
children with autism and people with
dementia and the field Grew From that
because they continue to use our field
for free they can have up to an hour per
week they can take that in one hour or
if they have a puppy a half hour
slot um at no time have dogs escaped
there was one dog that did eat some
chickens but it was a good dog lots of
the stories that have come up about our
application have been
heay um we have withdrawn wanting to
have
parties to help our neighbors we are
very helpful we hope to our neighbors
and the one neighbor who spoke used to
walk his dog in our field and there is a
gate in one of the photos that I showed
you that is called Amber's gate and that
is the objective
dog uh the river does not cause a
problem because the other side they have
CCTV and I know very well that Karen
bird would have been on the phone to me
instantly if we had any
problems whenever a new person comes if
they decide not to park on the road then
we check where they have parked if
they've parked on the pavement we ask
them not to next time time nobody that
we have seen has ever parked in an
inconsiderate place and if they had we
would have ask them to move we encourage
them to come down to the field but I
can't make them they never reverse down
the drive because we have the Turning
facilities they are always considerate
to all our neighbors and one of our
neighbors has written a letter of
support to say without one of my dog
walkers capturing her escapee he would
have disappeared in
Stratford uh we also have dogs not from
centry we have meon Vale we have
Stratford we have welcome Hills we have
Wellford um we have dorsington and we
have the
village any questions please do
say thank you very much uh both um
straight in with the questions councilor
Harvey thank you very much for your um
your
words
um one of the points made by the obors
is that the
objections have come from people who
live outside Clifford Chambers uh sorry
the objections have come from people who
live inside Clifford James and the
supporters who come live outside um can
you give us any rough appreciation of
What proportion of dog walkers who use
your facility are from within Clifford
Chambers yeah y there are
four out of there are it I think about I
have some really regular people who've
come forever in a day um I should say
about
30 thank you I have used it before my
dog died bit difficult
since thank you um condolences um uh
councelor Parry you hello good e good
evening um I wonder whether you can
explain how you monitor your bookings
and
access um for the bookings onto the
field so that only the requisite number
of people go there and how long they
stay um how you're able to monitor if I
explain the booking system would would
that be fine that would be helpful I'm
just thinking of control for Access yeah
um in your particular instance as a dog
owner you would go onto my Facebook page
you then click on the book Now button it
takes you to a system called simply book
it you put your name your email how many
dogs you're bringing and there's also a
a bit that says do you want to say
anything
else I they then receive a confirmation
email
they then receive a welcoming email from
me stating all their terms and
conditions they then have to go to our
Facebook page and they have to agree to
the terms and conditions which they open
up in the top post they are very strict
I am a horse riding teacher I am a very
strict person um they never come without
being met by either miles or myself when
we re explain those
rules councelor Keithley
next thank you yeah and thank you Sarah
and Linda uh question really for you
Linda um Andrew commented about people
getting up close to his boundary and
sitting under the tree and I think we
would acknowledge that having someone at
the bottom of your garden in a rural
setting is is probably a bit intrusive
and we try not to do that what can you
tell us about mitigation attempts or or
things that you're doing to keep people
a little bit further away from the
boundaries of of the likes of Andrew's
Back Garden I did look at putting up
Emer and I did look at putting up Harris
fencing and having a h hedge between the
Harris fencing and the properties I
spoke to a number of people who didn't
object and that they wouldn't like at
all they all their Gardens are based so
that they have a view over our field um
I think it would be wrong to do that so
we are putting in indigenous
hedging um I'm afraid that takes some
years to grow the Harris fencing can
also only go up to six feet the hedging
I can allow to grow as much as I like I
did notice on the subject of hedging
that counselor Tri I was very
concerned that people could look out um
we do an awful lot for the field I'm the
trustee of a The Village
Eco wild about Clifford we have walks
around everybody who doesn't have a dog
is very happy to walk on my land for a
wild about Clifford meeting they'll walk
on the land after dark we had a bat
detection
so quick followup to that Linda
um I appreciate all the things that you
do on the field I you've told me this
before would would it be possible for
you to consider maybe um I know the
field does flood sometimes as well would
it be possible for you to consider a few
way marker posts rather than fencing
fencing I could understand people
wouldn't want something that was coun
Keith I'm afraid we're looking for
questions well the question is could you
consider something that would keep
people away from we've got to bear in
mind that the application that's in
front of us has been considered by
officers I think we'll leave it to that
thank you any further questions
councilor P thank you chair just to
clarify something I I I listened to your
explanation about how you run the system
and I I picked up that there is a meet
and greet uh is there always somebody
you know yourself or I think you
mentioned your husband your husband
husband uh is there always somebody on
the field while the field is being used
or once the meet and greet has happened
do you do you go off somewhere and and
how close are you are you quite close
everybody has my mobile telephone number
okay and and are you you're you're in
Clifford itself aren't you that correct
I live in Clifford I live right by the
field we bought it because it was at the
back of our house I I so after the meet
and greet uh you leave the dog walkers
for their session and absolutely thank
you I just wanted just to clarify the
the sort of far end of the system if you
will if we go if we go on holiday it's
closed okay thank you very much that's
that's that's helpful thank you back to
councelor
Harvey thank
chairman one of the problems with any
condition is that it has to be
reasonable councel Harvey very very
quickly do you mind moving your
microphone slightly close to you thank
you um one of the issues with conditions
is that they have to be reasonable and
enforceable have you ever had to
sanction in some way or another one of
your existing dog walkers uh
yes I have um they were playing
football and um I went down the field
and because I could hear it um and asked
them not to play
football um and they were completely
understanding but they play football a
lot with their dog and I felt it was too
noisy so they went to using one of those
skimming things which is silent that is
also the skimming I don't know what you
call them fris frisbees the frisbees are
also one thing that dogs for good use a
lot to encourage the puppies to bring
back your sock your boot whatever your
mobile telephone whatever you require
it's an encouragement for the dog to
come back um and so um if there were any
frisbees they'd have been dogs for
good councilor pattingham
now yeah the the biggest problem I hear
about dogs is their poo so not
a so how how do you deal with the
problem yes um they sign up to say they
will pick up when we meet and greet we
say if you see one that you haven't done
do a favor pick it up we had a lady come
the other day because she likes the fact
that she never finds dog poo on our
field and she was able to bring her dog
this isn't the most Pleasant subject but
some dogs do take to eating other dogs
yeah um the dogs for good must not do
that um and so this lady was able to
come because her dog had started to do
that and she could be assured and she
knew that the field was going to be
clean my husband and I also walk around
every
evening to
check thank you any further
questions quickly one quick one have you
got a dog poo bin on the site I've got
three thank you uh okay uh I think
that's it for member questions thank you
very much for your contribution this
evening ladies and go and sit down then
yes thank you very brief comment no uh
I'm sorry I I
we're going to have to restrict it to
that just press the right
hand thank you very
much right uh members we'll now move on
then to points of clarification for our
officers straight in councilor P thank
thank you chair uh top of page for uh
Highway officer raises concerns with the
proposed amendments consider unclear uh
ask for further Clarity uh I can't see
any anything in the update sheet
providing further Clarity uh can can you
provide that further Clarity that I
assume you have in front of you from the
highways
officer so the highways officer has not
submitted any additional comments but I
was satisfied based on the information
before me that it was obvious what the
vehicle movements were going to be from
the variation of condition we're
securing parking spaces within the site
by conditions so even though they have
not followed up with a comment I think
that we can assess the highway
impacts on our own chair if I can I just
clarify that clarify that further
Clarity um as I read this the the County
officer is asking for further Clarity
are you saying that you've then
responded to that and then had no
further response from the highway
officer because if if the officer's
asking for some further Clarity it may
be clear to you but it's not clear to
the highway officer and if we've not
responded I just just it we seem to have
a position where we've got something in
front of us
where the highway the highway team are
not clear and if you haven't if they've
asked a question you haven't gone back
to them with an answer I'd say I'm a bit
I'm uncomfortable with that but I I wait
to hear what you or David have got to
say so our my recommendation's been made
on the basis that I don't consider the
conditions that we've proposed to be
Mater like to have materially impacted
on highway safety so
the the traffic generation we've said is
negligible and we've secured the same
number of parking spaces within the site
so we were comfortable that the highway
safety and parking impacts were
acceptable okay um any further points of
clarification yeah please um J members
questioning um of speakers a matter was
raised in respect of um certificate
relating to the ownership of the site as
set out in our update sheet the
ownership of land and the rights whether
or not to pass over the land are private
matters and are usually held separate
from um planning considerations it is a
lawful necessity that an appropriate
certificate has been served that
reflects the ownership of the site um
before a decision is made um I can't
resolve that matter at the current time
so I'm asking members if you were to
resolve to approve this application in
accordance with our recommendation that
that be delegated back to officers um so
that we may do that once a appropriate
certificate can be confirmed to have
been uh signed and received by the
planning
Authority Council
Perry thank you David for that should we
then not also um be awaiting
confirmation from morire County highways
that they wish to remove their objection
because they're then satisfied with the
points that you have made officer's view
is that the application before members
because there's an existing planning
consent for the use and what we're
looking at is a minor change to the
hours of using the land is that this
doesn't have substantive impacts subject
to the conditions on the highway highway
so we think that although there is as
you say an outstanding objection from
the County Council that doesn't prevent
members from resolving to approve the
application um members are entitled to
take a different
view thank you Council
pton apologies chair so if I look at the
table at the on page four and
five what is permissioned
is six bookings
and if I turn to page 133 that's eight
bookings that's an increase of a third
and I know we're talking about low
numbers here
um the number of parking spaces has not
changed if I take again just to go back
to my original question your your
position is that an additional two
bookings per day with a maximum of two
vehicles per for each of those bookie
which is an extra four vehicles per day
is um even if the County Highway officer
appears to lack clarity as to what's
being asked your your stance as the
planning officers and the planning the
case officer and and the planning
manager there is that that increase in
in traffic
is not of the order that requires you to
specifically go back and answer the
question orbe it that I would observe
chairman that as a a matter of good
practice I think if any stakeholder or
consulty has questions they should be
responded to I I just make that as an
observation that would seem to be good
practice and certainly would preclude
members from Raising this if because you
know we do need to ensure we've got
these things bottomed out so I think if
uh if David takes that on board for
future applications it is unhelpful if
there is some ambiguity around
stakeholder input when we as a committee
are coming to consider applications and
I'll leave it at
that I think that in response to that I
take that on board um I don't think that
there is ambiguity in respect of the
impacts that this would have on the
highway as you say it's pretty clear how
many additional um cars might arrive
it's pretty clear from the other
conditions that they will be separated
and that they will be limited to an hour
on the site each and that the time that
they're allowed to operate the site for
will mean that those additional arrivals
will be spread across the day I think
it's regrettable that the County Council
have been unable to um perhaps decipher
that um to their own satisfaction but
for planning officers of this Authority
it seems fairly clear what the impacts
will be and it's straightforward for us
to make our
recommendation thank you coun
har I noticed in giving that
reply um you you accept or you
implicitly you accepted councelor pem's
assertion that this will lead to two
additional bookings I draw your
attention eight paragraph
three the name just one fing per day is
it one or two I know we're talking about
small numbers councel pton but it's 50%
or
100% so it depends on what time of year
so because the opening hours differ
across the months in some pit uh months
they'll be allowed one in some months
they'll be allowed two additional
bookings thank you for the clarification
C that's a
draw uh yes can I just ask the officers
regarding the conditions we had one of
the
speakers um at the beginning of the
presentation make reference to whilst
there be six adults wondered whether
there could be a split from adults to
children and I just wonder what the
officer's view of that
particular suggestion would
be my initial reaction would be that it
would be potentially
unenforceable um to to really get down
to that level of detail for visitors at
any given
time any further points of clarification
no in which case we can move to debate
who would like to
start Al I'll start picking on
somebody um out of character for for
committee but I'll start the debate
myself um broadly speaking um I've I
feel that the speakers that we've had
tonight have each been very useful uh to
Committee in their own specific ways I'm
certainly aware of the concerns of the
um Parish Council and I think that
they're doing a um doing their role in
representing residents fairly um
conscientiously um in the concerns that
they may have that being said I think it
was the second speaker Mr Musgrave who
um indicated that he was broadly happy
with certain aspects of this um proposal
on the basis that it was a more consent
ious approach to the use of the land um
which then seemed to be backed up by the
the supporters on that basis I'm um I'm
aware that there's been some
uh uh the word escapes me but it's given
give and take between officers and the
applicants which is um wiow down the
impact that this could have had had they
had exactly what they'd proposed
initially on that basis I think we've
got before us something that's broadly
acceptable and have a reasonable impact
on the area for that reason I'm in
support of it and I think it would be uh
unreasonable for us to go against I'd be
certainly in intrigued to see what other
members would say but that's my position
uh who would like to go next councelor
Perry thank you chair um first of all I
thought I found it very helpful uh to
gain a greater understanding of the
booking system and the access and the
controls um and I I'm comfortable that
there are clearly some very detailed
terms and conditions for the users of
the field um which I think is to be
welcomed um there's obviously great
pride I mean I think one of the key
things is to look at the actual size and
scale of the field we have here this is
a very large for someone who who walks
their dog um on a daily basis I don't
have the luxury of that sort of space so
it is a very large area um and I think
it is um certainly the the
applicants um by what they've actually
said and the the the the principles
they've put in place um they're being
very careful about the the state of the
field and monitoring it I like the fact
that when they go on holiday they close
the booking system because there's no
one to be able to come back um I think
my major concern is that um as a member
of the planning committee to be sitting
here and having an objection from
warshire County highways makes me feel
very
uncomfortable um
however um you know I I appreciate the
case officer and planning managers have
given this great attention to detail um
we are looking at a variation we're not
looking at a new planning application in
front of us um and therefore on that
basis and I think that the conditions
are reasonable I will second the
application because I can see no
material planning reason for refusal
thank you chair thank you very much um
so initially I hadn't intended to make a
formal proposal but um on that basis of
you willing to Second it I'm happy to uh
go back and make a proposal uh councelor
pton
thank thank you chair
um I am struggling to find any planning
reasons uh that would cause me to go
against the office's recommendations on
on in this matter it's an appropriate
use of a field in a in uh in in the
countryside um I do however want to put
a marker down
um applications get varied and then the
further application to be varied to me
listening to the uh speakers tonight
this is more about a management issue
than a planning issue it's about the
impact of the operation of this site on
the residents of Clifford Chambers and
legitimate concerns have been raised um
I for one uh and this is the marker I'm
laying down would be uncomfortable about
seeing any further variation on the
planning conditions for the operation of
this site coming forward anytime soon I
think uh this is not uh and this is
right at the edge uh and is not strictly
relevant but I think it would be wise of
the applicant to demonstrate a trap
record of uh creating no further concern
for residents should they ever have any
Ambitions to move forward and should
consider uh an appropriate timeline that
is not something that anybody can
control and clearly officers would um uh
consider there any applications that
comes by but I I for one would struggle
with that and I do realize that probably
does probably knock me out of any future
application but somebody's got to say
it thank you Council
pton no I appreciate your input to that
um any further yes councelor strander hi
I really appreciated all the details
that were provided this evening um it
seems to me that that the big biggest
objection to this has to do with parking
issues um and I sadly there hasn't been
any concrete evidence um to to
demonstrate a problem or not a problem
um I do feel reassured by the
arrangements that seem to be imp placed
by the owners to encourage appropriate
parking um for people that come to visit
um I think the noise um objection is
also worth considering um and I think
the Restriction of six people will help
mitigate against that um I also um think
that in terms of our hotter Summers that
we're experiencing the extension of the
hours in the summertime is appropriate
as a dog owner in the summer I do walk
my dog in the cooler part of the evening
um and so I think that probably overall
I would be in support of the officer's
recommendations as well thank you thank
you very much um I just point out at
this point that uh The Proposal that I'm
that I made um for approval is on the
basis that the issues surrounding the
ownership certificate are delegated to
officers so that that is not what the
committee is determining this
evening yeah as well as the update sheet
um are there any further speakers on
this item no in which case we can go to
the
vote okay so proposal is to Grant
application
2390 vary can I see all those in favor
please that's unanimous okay in which
case uh committee resolves to Grant
application
23239 very River Meadow dog
walking subject to uh the update sheet
conditions and the ownership certificate
uh issues being resolved by
officers right thank you very much
everybody
good right we'll now move on then to
item four which is application
0fu well Cottage the Green snitter
Field our presenting officer is Sarah
Leech uh we'll give her a minute to uh
um get situated and then uh we can take
it
away
uh good evening thank you chairman this
proposal is seeking planning permission
for the change of use of land to the
eastern boundary of well Cottage
demolition of Garden Wall construction
of new wo and Boundary treatment to give
4.1 MERS access to the rear the
application site is located on the green
within the village of snitterfield and
can be identified by the black
dot the application site is outlined in
red which is located within the sneville
conservation area which is outlined in
purple the green dash line represents
public foot paaths the application site
is also located in the green Bel and
Arden special landscape
area this aerial photo shows the
application site and its surroundings
this photo was taken in
2021 this site plan shows the two new
dwellings which the access will serve
which are to the northwest of well
Cottage the access track runs along the
eastern boundary of well
Cottage um this site plan shows the uh
shows the existing boundary sorry
existing wo and Boundary treatment which
is highlighted in
yellow seen here and the new wall and
fence boundary treatment which is
highlighted in blue the existing hedge
has been
removed it is proposed to replant a
hedge in front of the uh close boarded
fence this will have a 400 MM width
planted uh planting bed the Hedge will
be grown and maintained at the height of
the fence which is 1.8
m uh the driveway uh beyond the first
7.5 M will be finished in
Stones here we have the existing and
proposed elevations of the wall and the
boundary
treatment and here are some photographs
of the application
site the wall and closeboard fence have
been constructed as can be seen in these
photos there will be public views
available of the development from the
green and from the access
track the officer recommendation is to
Grant this application subject to the
conditions and notes set out in the
report and the updates on the update
sheet thank you very much Sarah okay we
move on then to our first Speaker who is
councelor Karen
Elliot good
evening okay uh so you have three
minutes um I have to give you a 30
second warning um when you're ready uh
but otherwise when you're ready feel
free to take it away it's just the
button on the right hand side to turn
the microphone
on
the parish council was supportive of the
original application to build two new
homes at the bottom of this access track
and was comfortable with the condition
imposed by highways that only the first
7.5 MERS of this track from the edge of
the public Highway needed to be widened
and serviced with tarmac the parish
council was not made aware that the
whole of this single track Access Road
beyond the first 7.5 M would need to be
widened to accommodate this development
together with removal of a 35.6 m length
mature dense Holly hedge one could
speculate that the applicant needed a
wider access road to make it easier to
take building materials up and down and
that is why without any consultation
with the parish council the applicant
decided to widen the remainder of the
access track to a width of 4.1 M lay
hard standing to the same width and
remove the whole 35.6 M length of mature
Holly hedge and repl place with a wooden
fence as you saw in the photo this has
completely changed the character of this
narrow axis Road in the conservation
area this retrospective planning
application seeks to justify and
accommodate the new road width created
without permission note well there are
still no statutary consuls in this
application that state that the access
road needs to be widened beyond the
first 7.5 M to mitigate the harm of
removing the mature hedge the
application commits to planting a new
hornbean hedge immediately to the front
of the new wooden fence however as the
application is requesting a width of 4.1
M for the access road this leaves no
width for the Hedge to be planted the
planning officer in her report on page
23 acknowledges the visual impact that
these fences can have on the character
of the conservation area but states that
the planting of the proposed hedge will
soften this impact and a condition will
be imposed which ensures that the
development is carried out in accordance
with the approved plans the Hedge it
density and survival as acknowledged by
the LPD is therefore crucial to preserve
the character of the conservation area
what is the point of approving this
planning application on condition that
the Hedge is planted but then the Hedge
does not survive because it's not been
given enough room for it to grow to the
same density it is regrettable that this
application has now been brought to
committee as the parish council requests
the applicant to withdraw and consult to
agree an acceptable maximum maximum wids
of the axis road which would both
conserve the couch of the conservation
area and ensure the new hedge was
planted to the same density with space
to thrive the parish council therefore
objects to this application as is
harmful to the character of the
conservation area and does not
positively contribute to local character
as per NDP be1 and my next speaker will
be showing photos of the before and
after photographs which you have not
seen you've just seen the after
photograph thank you very much just
within your time members do we have any
questions for our Parish Council
Representative no in which case thank
you very much for your contribution
thank
you so now move on to councilor Parker
good evening um I might to understand
mck Flanigan isn't with uh with us this
evening that's correct chair I'm afraid
uh Mr Flander couldn't make it I'll be
speaking on his behalf but speaking also
as just a parisher in this instance
absolutely that's that's fine uh you've
got 3 minutes also um and again I'm
happy to give you a 30 second warning
before the time is up thank you well
thank you chair and committee members um
I want to bring two points which are
broadly the same points as you've just
heard but with with a slightly different
emphasis I I too am frustrated that this
um is before you today because uh it's
um an incoherent application it requests
S A 4.1 clear access but then says
there'll be a hedge of 400 MM in front
of it so my math says that's 3.7 M so it
provides a 3.7 M clear access which uh
is not required um to well to just
deliver such huge Devastation and I'd
like to look at the picture this is what
we had before and now if you could move
on to the next picture this is what
we've got now this is in a Conservation
Area it's in the green belt and it's in
the Arden conservation area as well the
Arden special landscape area the damage
within the conservation area is
extraordinary and I I think it doesn't
need me to read out all of the different
uh planning guidance I think the only
bit I I would refer to is that in
conservation areas you require careful
very careful consideration in the
development process it requires their
preservation or enhancement and it
should be the mo one of the most
important factors in determining a
planning application so we have a
planning application in front of us and
the most important thing we should be
considering is the conservation of of
the area thank you very
much thank you very much well within
your time uh members do we have any
questions councelor
Perry thank you and good evening um can
you just give me some clarity on the
public views if we could possibly um
have the previous picture
up yes uh and the the the one
before that's the past one and then
we've got a the new one yes so holy
smoke that one so in terms of public
views if you're you're coming
into if if you're sort the bottom of it
would you would you automatically walk
up that area or is that just for the two
new dwell dwellings uh so this no this
is uh a fabulous uh little route that
takes you up to the allotments so all
the allotments are up here and there's
some garages and there's access to a
couple of houses um so so it's used by
pedestrians with with forks and Spades
uh and it's used by a couple of cars
normally now obviously uh as um
counselor um Elliot has has said it's
been widened I guess to to allow large
Machinery access for the development
that's due to take
place thank you any further questions
counc
Harvey Mr D in these
circumstances can I just read to you one
sentence from the officers report and
ask you for your response to it it's on
page
23 although there will be public views
of the war not considered to
detrimentally impact on the character of
Conservation Area to a significant
extent which is a view shared by the
council's conservation
team uh so I mean I I would urge you to
draw your own conclusions yeah I mean
the report says that there's uh no
visual harm arising and will not harm
its character either but uh I I
think the photographs speak loud enough
thank you and any further questions
councelor H hello there is is there an
ownership of this uh driveway at all uh
the the ownership is a bit complicated
because there are many including the
parish council that have a right of way
uh an easement on this land but it's
only to the right hand side of this land
not to the left hand side which of
course is uh the land taken from wel
Cottage okay thank
you thank you any further
questions no in which case um thank you
for your contribution to this this
evening thank
you right we'll move on then to our
final speaker who is Vicky
Potter U so just uh yeah sorry I was
going to say I've just got yourself down
as the speaker very good uh so you have
six minutes um happy to give you a 30
second warning as well um otherwise when
you're ready take it away thank you good
evening my name is Vicky Potter I'm the
architect representing the applicants
Hawker construction who have purchased
the site at the rear of well Cottage and
the 4.1 meter access driveway just to be
clear the driveway is owned by the
applicants even though there are a right
of ways by others along it the photos
that are on the screen show the driveway
in question the driveway is off the
green and serves the allotments as well
as the new housing site at the back I
take full responsibility that the
widening of this driveway was not
explicit in the original outline
application at that point we believ the
boundary on the other side of the drive
to be slightly further north and the
wall of cobbler's Cottage had not been
built Hawker construction held an open
evening to Lea with the neighbors and
they met on site with them to agree the
exact positions of the boundaries on the
ground before starting any work it
became clear that the boundary on the
neighboring land was slightly further
south and the boundary between the drive
and well Cottage needed to be
repositioned the original outline
approval was conditional on the access
driveway being 5 m wide for the first 7
and 1 half meters off the green and
tarmacked in this area the photos you've
just seen from the previous speaker show
this first 7 and 1 half meters from the
green this T area has already been
approved the area in question tonight is
the remaining length of the drive which
has been set at the 4.1 M the parish c
um the previous speaker questioned the
width of this building regulations Part
B states that a fire engine needs 3.7 M
curb to curb for Access we have allowed
an additional 20 cm tolerance either
side which seems reasonable giving a
total width of 4.1 M down this driveway
this information has been shared with
the planning
officers the widening of the drive is a
statutory requirement to access the new
houses at the rear of well Cottage it
will be finished in permeable Stone
chippings which are appropriate to the
conservation
area I know that the reinstatement of
the wall and fence should have waited
for the determination of this
application but it has been four months
since we submitted the application and
the home own Homeowner of well Cottage
was extremely concerned about their priv
pracy and
security he placed a legal obligation on
the applicants to erect the new boundary
treatments within a very limited time
frame and that is the only reason why
this wall and fence have already been
erected the new wall and fence were on
the land belonging to well Cottage and
are not in the applicant's
ownership this planning application was
originally submitted for the wall and
fence as you can see on the screen on
the left hand side there however the
parish council objected to the fence and
insisted that we plant a hedge in front
of
it we personally felt that a hedge would
create an onerous ongoing maintenance
issue for the residents of the new
houses being constructed however we have
taken on board their request and propose
a new single row hornbeam hedge in front
of the fence on the green unstoned area
that you can see in the photo just to
the left
there Hawker construction do not own the
wall or fence and cannot therefore
remove or adjust them as already stated
we need a minimum of 3.7 M for emergency
vehicles which leaves 40 cm left over on
the
driveway all the applicants can
therefore do to meet the parish
council's requests is to plant the
required hedge in this 40 cm gap on
their own land the applicants cannot
widen this driveway there is no other
land in their
ownership if I draw your attention to
the photographs again you will see that
there is a green space alongside the
drive on the right hand side but this is
not in hawker's ownership the
neighboring land owners could put a
fence or building on that land on the
right at any time and so this cannot be
relied upon for access to the new houses
or for the allotments at the top of the
drive to reiterate the parish council
have objected to the proposals because
they require the Hedge to be wider this
is simply impossible Hawkers do not own
any more land and a wider hedge would
block the emergency access driveway to
the houses at the back our landscape
designers FFC Landscape Architects who
we have worked with on this project have
stated that a 40 cm trench will be
sufficient to allow the Hedge to
establish and grow they have asked for
the drive to be edged with a Timber
board not a conrete curb but confirm
that and I quote a hedge trench 40 cm
wide and 45 cm depth would be enough to
sustain a hedge for many many years that
is their professional opinion on it and
I have forwarded their statement to the
planners
already looking back at the photos on
the screen you will see that this part
of the conservation area is lined with
neighbor sheds parked cars and other
close boarded
fences there are identical Timber fences
between the neighboring Gardens and on
the other boundaries of well
Cottage this is a private driveway and
is not accessible to the general public
even even though there are some rights
of way for the Neighbors along it in my
opinion the wall and the new fence make
a positive impact on this driveway the
applicants have done the applicants they
have done everything they can to meet
the requirements of the neighbors and
the parish council and create a secure
boundary treatment for well Cottage that
enhances the conservation area the
planning officers support this
application we feel that the parish
council's requests to widen the proposed
hedge take no regard to the St statutary
requirements of building regulations the
fact that this is a private driveway or
the appearance of the neighboring
properties on the other side of this
drive thank you hang on six minutes
thank you very much uh members do we
have any questions councilor
pmon thank you chair thank you uh for
that so can I so the the close boarded
fence uh
replaces some mature hedge r correct and
if I hear what you said in your
statement your rationale for that was
Bas it's a little bit difficult to keep
it mode and uh trimmed uh I think you
use the phrase about uh inord inordinate
maintenance I wonder if you could just
expand on that because what we appear to
be faced with is the destruction of a
buture hedge in a conservation area just
because it's a little bit difficult to
keep it going what you know to to
maintain it um I'd like to I'd like to
understand why practically uh I'm not
looking at a a brick wall and then uh a
mature hedge rub along there okay so the
previous hedge was further out into
where the driveway is currently no
planning permission is required to take
a hedge down um even in a Conservation
Area um the owner of well Cottage wanted
to secure their boundary which would
have been left open once that hedge had
been removed um to put a hedge instead
of that fence Hedges obviously take a
while to to grow up would have left that
boundary open and unsecured and
unprivate for a good amount of years
until it had grown dense enough to
completely secure that
boundary um the ownership Hawker
construction's ownership goes up to that
fence so anything that is planted in
front of that secure fence is going to
be the responsibility of the new
homeowners in the properties at the back
we were concerned about giving them that
obligation longterm but of obviously are
proposing to put the Hedge there because
that is what the parish have requested
that we do but that is the reason why we
hadn't originally offered it
up thank you just so if I can just come
back on
that what you're telling me is that the
original hedro in there leaving it in
place wouldn't have allowed you
sufficient room to get a fire engine up
there
correct so what you've done is
retrospectively just taken that out
because you can't get over the access
which if you'd have left it in for the
planning application you'd have failed
on that am I am I wrong in that
assessment the position of the boundary
on the right hand side of the driveway
here hasn't changed what you you you've
you've you've created an access that
wasn't there just by ripping that hedge
out could be concise and not debate R
thank
you uh would any other members have to
ask a question of our applicants
Representative no in which case thank
you for your contribution this
evening okay uh we now move on to points
of clarification from our officers uh
any points of
clarification coun Keith Le yeah thanks
chair uh yeah as a point to clarify
equation on the public views up into
this um Access
Lane on page 23 you say that um the
rebuilding of the wall further along the
access road will have less of a public
impact use the distance from the green I
haven't I don't think I've seen anything
from the green to see what my view is of
this Access Road uh so have you got
something this is a view up from the
green ah the green is the highway that
runs so is the green the road directly
that takes you to this access so it's is
not a green as such it is the road name
thank you very much for that
worries further points clarification
councelor
Fleming um when you were considering
this application um was the five meters
at 5 meters width at the front was that
to allow for bin storage for or for
vehicles to pass I just wonder what the
rationale was for having five meters for
the first seven and a half meters and
then coming down to 4.1 we all know the
fire RS and all of those sort of things
because we've done about three or four
of these in the last six months of these
sorts of things so we appreciate the
fact that before when it was only 3.1 it
would have never got past planning
anyway because of that um so was the F
what the question sorry I get back to
the question the first 7 and a half
meters at 5 meters wide does that
account for bin storage and whatever
else for on bin day uh
it's a standard condition of the highway
Authority and it's not usually um
motivated by a requirement to place bins
although that is obviously quite often
what it gets used for I think the reason
the highway authorities seek for these
sorts of Junctions to be widened is so
that if there's a car waiting to emerge
onto the green another car can exit off
of the green without needing to stop
traffic in in the other Highway and
cause um issues on The Wider Highway
Network
councilor
pattingham in in a case like this where
a hedge has been taken out without
planning
permission not quiet it's not required
not sorry I'll let you finish your
question but uh planning permission is
not required to remove a hedge oh right
yes yeah sorry uh any further points
clarification no in which case we can
move to debate who would like to start
councelor Parry
thank you chair um obviously the key
concerns raised by the parish council
would appear to be harm to the
conservation area and the character of
the conservation area um but our
conservation team very very clearly
State as far as they
concern that there is no harm being
there is no significant harm being
caused by the proposals in front of us
and and actually goes on to say that um
they are satisfied that the proposal
Accords with policies cs8 and policy be1
for my um for my um bit for what it's
worth is I know the conservation team
are actually very meticulous more often
than not we're trying to to battle
against the conservation team and here
we have them categorically saying there
is not significant harm to this area and
therefore you know it falls on on that
basis and therefore I'm very happy to
propose Grant um because as much as I
understand from the parish's perspective
um they're not conservation experts so
therefore I'm I'm pleased to propose
that we Grant um we Grant approval for
this application on the grounds of the
conservation officers
report thank you very much councelor
Perry councelor Harvey uh yes thank you
for that chairman I thought the
architect director gave a quite
convincing presentation I thought that
the that she her reference to public
consultation I thought that was a point
in her favor uh I I think the question
of having an expert's opinion that 40 40
cm by 45 cm depth produces a um a trench
which is sufficient for a hedge it may
not be the best but it's sufficient from
an expert's point of view we have advice
from the conservation officer that he's
happy this is a private road which the
public don't have a right of way to
although there are easements over it I
I'm persuaded that uh this is an
application we should support the
officer's um recommendation and I'm
happy to second Council Perry's
proposal uh thank you um might to mind
elaborating on that I'm just going to
ask um Mr Jeff to uh raise a point um in
relation to the
debate yeah um query was just raised as
to whether the conservation officer was
aware of the proposed condition in the
update sheet at the point at which they
made their comments I can confirm that
they were not um the condition proposed
in the update sheet would be in addition
to um the conservation officers
views thank you um for my part I'll I'll
jump in at this point I feel reading the
update and and the uh the addition of
the Hedge that that effectively um
requires I would be satisfied for my
view that it would be within um my
expectations for for what the
conservation officer is speaking about
on this regard so for my part I would be
um happy that that falls within what's
being proposed but obviously that's
that's for you um as proposer uh
councilor
pton thank you chair and I can read the
room um I I would observe that my
concern is that we're achieving a
suboptimal outcome here there was a
mature hedge um that uh
contributed to the setting um we now
have a close boarded fence which is a
which is's an
urbanized um uh asset uh and and does
not do anything to enhance the setting
um and
um I hear what other members say um uh
but with my cynical hat on I'm
absolutely in the place that think that
that this this was merely to um
facilitate the uh an access width that
wasn't actually there in the first place
and as I say we achieve a suboptimal
outcome because we replace uh what on
the face of that those other P the
earlier pictures was uh an asset in
terms of a mature hedge um and I am
uncomfortable with that allbe it that I
do concur with my uh member colleagues
that uh uh I'm struggling for a planning
reason to actually sort of go against it
but I'm really uncomfortable about it
thank you councilor pemon um I I do
understand your your position on that I
think the my view in relation to that
point exactly is the amount of control
we have as the local planning Authority
and and that extends out to the parish
council view I can completely sympathize
being a parish counselor myself this is
the type of thing that we do um
obviously have concerns about but as a
local planning Authority we have
toled that there is there is an absence
of a policy hook here uh any further
contributions to the
debate no in which case we have a
proposal uh to Grant in line with the
officers recommendations and the update
sheet um proposal made by councelor
Parry seconded by councelor
Harvey uh can I see all those in favor
please that's
unanimous thank you very much in which
case uh committee resolves to Grant
application
0fl
okay item five urgent business no urgent
business in which case the meeting is
closed